Nó này 1 bốn tháng 18, tông tin từ công an tình đồng này, đơn vị đang tiếp tục với một số đơn vị như vụ của bộ công an, tất trung đưa ra, chỉ sẽ làm sõ vụ án dưới,
cứ tệ sản sế ra tại Đại Li thu mua nông sản thình hạnh, thuộc biệt bản thu sấu, sả đất nhau, hệ đủ đăng cú, tình đồng này.
Bù án được phát hiện vào khoảng 20 dương em ba tháng 18, tạng 18, phê tế về phát hiện 2 vợ trong chủ Đại Li thu mua nông sản thình thạnh,
sinh năm 18, 18, 18, 18, cùng người châu trời, sinh năm 18, tụi chồng em bốn đều đã thử vòng.
Ngay sau khi tiếp nhận tìm máu, nhận định đầy là vụ án có tính trước đặc biệt nghiêm sọc, đồng xí thêu tưởng với nước hay,
giả nó công an tình đã phân công các đồng xí đại tál lên mạnh hủ. Phó giám đốc, tụi chừng các quả kẻ rất đường tra,
đồng xí đại tál lâm văn lọc, phó giám đốc đến nơi hiện chờ, chứ tiếp xí đạo đường tra.
Đồng thời, vô việc đường báo ngay lên lãnh đạo bụ công an và các cuộc nghiệp vụ. Lãnh đạo cuộc kẻ rất hiện sự
vợ việc qua phing sự cũng đã phân công các tụi cũng tám ra phối hợp, bố trở công an tình đồng này.
Khi bỏ khám nghiệp hiện chương, khám nghiệp từ thí rất định, các bạn nhìn từ vòng đều gió bị đạn mắn vào đâu.
Chị sức camera của gia đình vào thời điểm xe ra vụ an, có một người đàn ông đựng bộ bảo hiểm chung khi mặt và đéo khổ trang xuất hiện trong sinh nhảnh.
Hẹn công an tình đồng này và lực lượng như vụ của bộ đăng tập trung tổ chức đều tra, chiến sát làm só hủ an.
Công an tình đồng này kêu hỏi mọi người dân nếu phát hiện đối tự kê an hoặc có thung tình đều quan.
Khi thời cũng cóp đến số định thoại không bà sống năm, bà sau sấu, mấy bầy bầy, đông xí lề vẫn,
trường phòng cạnh rất hiện sự, công an tình đồng này.